judith pogar is considered the strongest
ever
female chess player and in this video
we're going to take a look at five
of her most excellent sounds like him
in bill and ted's adventure now moves
and i have to say she was a tactical
genius and some of these moves are
simply stunning make sure you like this
video and subscribe to the chess.com
channel
and we're going to move on to some
beautiful
beautiful moves on the chessboard now
we're starting off with a nice easy
tactic just to get you in the right
fame of mind in this one judah is
playing against
pavlina chili guerrero off and
it's judit to play and win just look out
for the back rank
if you struggle with any of the tactics
i show you do press and use that pause
button
let's see if you can play like the great
judit
queen takes f8 check oh
yeah and here black resign because after
king takes the bishop is going to slip
into h6
and there comes the back ranker
nice and simple they will get harder i'm
warning you now
i'm warning you now this game is
considered one of judah's most amazing
and tremendous ever games and it's clear
why
judith is playing against vichywan anand
one of the strongest players of all time
one of the things personally i liked
about and do like about judith's play
is her tremendous energy she kept on
just
throwing pieces the kitchen sink there's
there's
there's there's i know a rock there's a
stone
there's a car she just kept throwing
everything at her opponents and
i've kind of modeled some my play on
this to
keep that pressure up it must have been
horrible
for her opponents to have this onslaught
coming against them
this is shown here white to play and now
judith comes in
with rug d6 another brilliantly
energetic
move this attacks the queen and of
course this queen is tied down to the
defense
of g7 if it moves away the queen
comes in checkmate on g7
so anand plays f6 but now bishop d2
and this lines up against the black
queen e4
another piece comes in b5 bishop e6
rook a7 and even though this next move
may seem a little bit odd it's one of my
favorite moves
in the whole game because it just
demonstrates that
judith understands that vishuan is
totally tied down here black is nearly
even in a position
of zugswang whatever move black plays
it can weaken his position and this
shows great understanding and just the
calm
rookie six dominates black's
position black tried a5 but this is a
nothing move
and now judith bit by bit improves her
position
and with rook c7 you can see the
pressure
mounting against black structure and
judith went on to win
even though she's a piece down black
just can't move brilliant brilliant
foresight
to make the sacrifice work and just look
at the energy
of white's pieces there
we now move on to one of my favorite
games of all time
often where you when you pair the
elements fire and fire
against each other you're gonna get an
explosion
and here you've got two of the best
attackers of all time judith
playing with the black pieces against
alexei shiroff
and here judit dives in with
queen takes g5 and this is
a way to stop not just win a pawn but
stop black from
castling queenside the idea of course is
that the queen has taken the knight will
come in
and win that queen the pawn on e4 is
actually pinned
down because of the rook and this is the
start of just an
amazing couple of moves here where the
black knights
really come to life shiro's problem is
his king
is a little bit more weaker he tried to
counter attack with knight
a5 hitting the bishop on b7 but judith
goes forwards and this next move must be
one of the most pleasurable moves she
had the chance to play i wish
i could play a move like this in my
lifetime knight
to e3 and this
just emphasizes her will and the way she
played
forwards never retreating unless she had
to
and playing with the utmost energy and
aggression
and one of the things that's interesting
here is well maybe
maybe white can take the queen now
thinking oh yeah thank you are you just
giving me your queen
are you gonna resign judith well
maybe i'll play a check it could be mate
just look at that
check mate oh oh it looks so good
and after knight e3 other options here
are very bad for example if white takes
on e3 grabs the bishop
then the combination of queen and knight
combine beautifully with knight f free
check and queen d2
ending in mate and if queen to g3
has played in the game well now judith
can just
win some material and she does and she
goes on to win
a lovely game and you're not going to
see many
nights combining to create a dance of
death like that
in your lifetime here judah is paired
against
fellow countryman fernandez burks and
in this position she sacrificed a piece
on g5
and black has recaptured here what
should and did she now play the obvious
move might be capturing that rook but
as you're probably guessing the obvious
move is not always
the one that should be played well the
move she played
shows brilliant understanding of the
position and
how to get through to the enemy's king
she always had our eyes on that king and
she always found
ways through often in a very direct
manner and the brilliant move here
is g4 now you might be thinking hang on
why is that brilliant
well it's brilliant because the idea is
to simply play h4
but stop black from playing g4
therefore whatever happens this h file
will become
open other moves were not as strong
this is directly going for the king my
kind of way of playing chess
and after rook b8 here she now goes
h4 and you can see this
file is opening and let's just have a
look how the attack continued
she now moves her queen into f4
and after bishop b7 yet another
brilliant move here
it's blow after blow we're up to h7
check
and now the point of this is the queen
comes to h2
and if king g7 we have queen h6
and rook to h1 and we can see it's going
to be checkmate coming up
the king went back to g8 rook h1 anyway
and after bishop takes g5 judith just
played
f4 and here black had to give up
his queen to stop check mate so judith
went on to win
lovely lovely energy yet again shown
with that brilliant attack
well if you know you're attacking player
you have to play attacking openings and
there's
not more of an attacking opening than
the king's indian defense
and in this position judith has black
against alexander
chernin and here we can see that
judith has a lot of pieces quite nastily
placed against that
king and after the move bishop d3 she
now
broke through how did she break through
she played rook takes g2 check
again forcing away through to the king
if king takes queen h3 as checkmate and
after
rook takes g2 just bishop takes h3
and this is building up to a major
discovered check
and with the other black rook coming in
white's king
is in the middle of an onslaught
the game continued knight to e4 and now
another piece comes in
typical judah every piece jumping into
action
knight takes e5 bishop takes e5 the
bishop
now lined up and after knight g5
well we can see that white is simply
lost as judith takes on g5
she's actually a pawn up here but with
rook g8 black
resigned after only one more move and
that is f3 with some nasty checks coming
next
deadly attacking play from jude
fantastic stuff
so which of those five moves was your
favorites they were
some stunning examples of energy
and using the initiative at the
chessboard we can all learn from
judith's play
and she was the strongest ever female
player
and a brilliant all-round chess player
being
one of the best in the world let's just
remember not just a strong female player
but one of the best chess players
combined with
any sex or whatever that's irrelevant
and we can see that from a brilliant
wins make sure you like
and subscribe to the channel and leave
your comments below